شكل اخر من اشكال هذه المعاناه مع استمرار
معاناه اللاجئين على الحدود طبعا القريبه
من السودان في دول مختلفه ومنها تشاد وهنا
السؤال موجه اليك فضل عبد الرزاق
نعم على الحدود التجاريه السودانيه
وتحديدا منطقه
ما زال اللاجئون السودانيون يصلون الى
تشاد ولكن عددهم اقل الان من
الكميات او العدد الذي كان يتدفق الى تشاد
بدايه
الازمه في السودان الذين وصلوا الى جهه
الان وتقدر عددهم السلطات بانهم اكثر من
عشره الاف اوضاعهم ما زالت سيئه هناك عدد
من المنظمات خاصه تلك المنظمات التابعه
للامم المتحده في الميدان معهم تحاول
تسجيل عددهم واحصاء الذين تمكنوا من
الوصول الى جادل من اجل تقديم ما يمكن
تقديمه من خدمات ولكن حتى الان المواد
الغذائيه وهي مطلب اساسي للاجئين لم تصل
الى كافه اللاجئين الذين وصلوا الى جادو
عددهم يزيد عن عشره الاف ومكث بعضهم اكثر
من عشره ايام دون ان يتلقى حتى الان اي
كميه من الغذاء بعض الذين حصلوا على
الغذاء من برنامج الغذاء العالمي الذي بدا
توزيعه على اللاجئين يتحدثون عن ان
الكميات التي حصلوا عليها لا تكفي لمده
عشره ايام ولكنهم يعدون انفسهم بانهم
حصلوا على شيء افضل من اولئك الذين لم
يحصلوا حتى الان ولا على كيلو جرام واحد
كما يقولون بالاضافه الى
المواد الغذائيه الجانب الطبي الجانبي
الصحي ايضا ما زال سيء في هذه المنطقه
التي
ينتشر فيها اللاجئين ووصلوا اليها من
الاراضي السودانيه وتحديدا من مدينه من
ولايه غربا دارفور المتاخمه للحدود هنا في
منطقه ادرياديه